good evening my name is Lynn Schaefer
and I'm coordinator or special projects
at the Smithsonian associates on behalf
of the Smithsonian it is my pleasure to
welcome you to our program tonight and
to introduce renowned author Anthony
beaver who will discuss his new
bestseller the fall of Berlin 1945 mr.
beaver is one of the most respected
military historians writing today
acclaimed for his vivid recreation of
some of the 20th century's most
significant battles he is the author of
the Spanish Civil War inside the British
Army and Crete the battle and the
resistance with his wife
Artemis Cooper he wrote Paris after the
liberation 1944 to 1949 his book
Stalingrad has been published in 19
languages and was awarded the first
Samuel Johnson prize for nonfiction the
Wolfson history prize and the Hawthorne
Dan prize for literature in it he gave a
riveting account of that crucial fearful
battle when Hitler's forces met their
match mr. beaver is a fellow of the
Royal Society of literature and a
Chevalier de loyola days are a day
Zettler in France he lives in the United
Kingdom we are delighted to have us have
him here with us this evening please
welcome mr. Anthony beaver
then thank you very much in January 1945
the Red Army launched its great winter
offensive from the river Vistula its
ultimate objective was Berlin MOT Soviet
propaganda called
the lair of the fascist beast in the
city itself the mood was a mixture of
fear resignation uncertainty and
cynicism eaten already at Christmas the
famous black humour of Berliners had
turned to gallows humor the joke that
season was be practical give a coffin
the question dominating their minds was
which enemy would reach Berlin first the
Western Allies or the Soviet Berliners
remarked that optimists were learning
English and pessimists were learning
Russian one well-known german journalist
who had been a member of the Hitler
Youth told me how he had entered a
grocery shop and called out the official
greeting of Heil Hitler
everybody in the long queue turned to
stare at him having been away from
Berlin you'd not realized how much
things had changed he never uttered the
words again except to Nazi Party
officials Nazi diehards had suddenly
become a minority they felt betrayed by
the Fairweather supporters of Hitler
those who now tried rapidly to distance
themselves from the regime and
responsibility for its actions the
question of how deeply Germans were
committed to Hitler a particular moment
has dogged the post-war debate for
decades when I was down in Bavaria
researching Stalingrad
I contacted Reinhardt bitsy Schmidt Cyr
had been Yocum von Ribbentrop smells
energetic aid in London and Berlin I'd
heard of his reputation for straight
speaking his memoirs in fact bear the
memorable title how we squandered the
right anyway there was no beating about
the bush with him I'm sure he told me
that most of those who have spoken to
have pretended that they were never
Nazis well it is not true we were all
not
is albert speer when interrogated by the
Americans some days after the end of the
war made a bitter observation history
always emphasizes terminal events he
said at that time Speer hated the idea
that the early achievements as he saw it
of Hitler's regime would be obscured by
its final grotesque
collapse he simply refused to recognize
that nothing reveals more about the true
nature of a dictatorship than the manner
of its downfall this is why the subject
of National Socialism final defeat is so
fascinating and also so important at a
time when teenagers especially in
Germany are finding much to admire in
the Third Reich the period never ceases
to be controversial as the recent the
protest demonstrations a few months ago
in Berlin over the verr marked war
crimes exhibition showed only - clearly
no country has done more in fact to face
up to the horrors of its own past than
Germany paced war generations of German
students have been out of openly
critical of their parents failure to
oppose or condemn the Nazi regime and
young German historians have done
everything they can to uncover evidence
of an SS or ver marked atrocities during
the invasion of the Soviet Union the
strength of feeling or moral aid outra
of moral outrage was so strong that it
did not always make for good history at
times one sensed that there was almost a
danger of what I might call moral
hypochondria everything was cast in such
degrees the black and white when their
often deep shades of grey and yet the
sense of disbelief and anger among the
younger generation is entirely sincere
and understandable even if it is
slightly self-absorbed after a lecture
which I gave in Hong Kong a young German
woman came up came up to me afterwards
and she wanted to talk about her
country's guilt for war crimes in the
Soviet Union her father had been an
officer in the Panzer divisions in annoy
stat but later came to regret deeply his
role in the vel Mart
you'd become a friend perhaps the most
controversial repentance in West Germany
at that time Count von ein steel a great
nephew of Bismarck and the dashing young
Luftwaffe fighter pilot eins needle
after his capture near Stalingrad in
September 1942 helped found the League
of German officers an anti-nazi
organization founded - under the control
of the Soviet NKVD
ein siedel had declared to this young
woman that the question affirm at war
crimes in Russia had been clear to
everyone from the beginning she and she
accepted this at face value yet it had
evidently not been clear to whine siedel
himself before his own Damascene
conversion well after the worst period
of her Martin SS atrocities in 1941 all
this goes to show that it is easy to
jump to moral judgment in retrospect
even when beating your own national
breast but what is far harder and far
more important is to understand the
mentality and the context of the times
which led to such atrocities the problem
of retrospective judgment and even
assessment is an important one - which
I'll return nothing as I say is black
and white in history
nothing is tidy and one must never
attempt to impose an ideological grid on
the subject the standard question how
could Germany the country of Schiller
and Beethoven and Goethe have committed
such barbarities is a misleading one
rather more to the point is how did a
country desperate for security and law
and order in the 1920s and 1930s blindly
follow the most reckless criminal world
has ever seen the short answer is that a
need to believe and a strong leader can
convert otherwise intelligent people to
willful blindness and a refusal to pose
pertinent questions about where such men
will lead them the normal rules of cause
and effect is passionately rejected and
by the time reality dawns it is too late
in Hitler's case predictions of the
threat from the communist East became a
self-fulfilling prophecy
after the vow masked brutal invasion so
too
did gobbles his horror propaganda after
the Soviet Union vowed revenge on
Germany for the terrible terrible
suffering inflicted on its people the
story of the last six months of the war
culminating in the Red Army's fearsome
assault on Berlin is also the story of
an increasing proportion of unwilling
soldiers and civilians trapped in a
nightmare of Nazi creation the Fury's
refusal to allow retreat meant the
German women and children were abandoned
in the face of the Red Army at times it
is hard to distinguish between the Nazis
almost unbelievable irresponsibility and
the total lack of humanity even towards
their own people in the course of the
ten weeks from mid January 1945 8.5
million refugees fled from East Prussia
West Prussia Pomerania and Silesia by
ship by train by farm cart and on foot
through deep snow and temperatures of up
to minus 30 degrees centigrade Soviet
tank units simply crushed refugee
columns under their tracks estimates of
those who died or were killed range from
half a million to over two million
people in Germany itself thousands of
refugees were left to freeze and starve
by the trainload in cattle and coal
wagon just like concentration camp
prisoners this was mainly because local
Nazi officials did not want the refugees
to pass on diseases in some cases they
simply shut the responsibility of
looking after them and sent them further
on down the line so much for the Nazis
volunteered Volks ganache and shaft or
sense of national comradeship it is
doubly unsettling to read these
documents in Berlin in the main archive
in the Finkelstein la the archive is
housed in the old barracks of Hitler's
bodyguard the SS livestand outer Adolf
Hitler and you crossed their parade
ground to get to the Reading Room's
former Soviet
archives can also have a disturbing
atmosphere they are also rather more
difficult to access than the German ones
in fact my first visit in 1995 to the
central archive of the Ministry of
Defense out of podolsk some 30
kilometers south of Moscow was quite an
education zamo as its call by its
initials were set up in 1936
coincidentally at the start of the
purges and some of the atmosphere still
lingers like the portraits of Lenin
staring down with a sinister gaze from
the wall our negotiations over access
the previous year had been conducted at
the Ministry of Defense with the
responsible officer on the General Staff
which directly controls the archives he
told me flatbeds Colonel turned a flat
lid that the way the system worked was
for me to tell them my subject and that
they would select the files it would
have been
needless to say futile to complain and I
spend I was interested in depicting the
experience of the soldiers on the both
sides during the Battle of Stalingrad
and to give an indication of the sort of
material I was looking for I mentioned
the in very interesting reports by
doctors and chaplains attached to the
German divisions which had found in the
German military archives at Freiburg
this prompted a bellow of laughter from
the Russian colonel there were no
priests in the Red Army
well I aside PI but you did have
political officers and this course
perfekt another laughs so you want to
see the political department reports he
said we'll see anyway Liuba Venna
granted by my research assistant in
russia where i worked with for over
eight years and I went out with certain
trepidation to Prados which used to be a
completely secret sealed city up until
1989 up until really the end of
communism
anyway we arrived there at podolsk on
the first morning in good time and
Colonel Shuba Xin who is then the deputy
director he is now the director showed
us the mountain of files that they had
extracted and selectively and pieces of
paper marked the passages chosen for us
and a tight sheet
gave a summary and it was clearly
forbidden to look outside the chosen
passages anyway we started off that
morning in the most extraordinary
conditions I've ever encountered in any
archive we had to sit and work on the
far side of Colonel Shaw versions desk
while he yelled into the malefactor
Shing telephone in he slammed down the
telephone and pointed to it in
frustration saying Soviet 1960s model it
would be easier to shop to Moscow just
to be on the safe side I decided to
begin with the dossiers of
interrogations of German prisoners which
curiously enough I knew would not be a
controversial or unsettling thing from
the Russians point of view and this did
prove a fortunate choice because at the
end of the morning a man appeared
wearing and this was good it was
wonderful when Mayweather I his grad
wearing dark glasses a beach shirt and a
moustache and he had a menacing
friendliness and spoke such good English
that in fact it could have only been
learnt abroad and so as a result I
realized that in he had GRU rational
intelligence written all over him
his name was Colonel Gregor yurevich
starkov and even i as i say the most
inexperienced boots bhaktas could see a
sort of more or less where he'd come
from shoe Roisin himself character
washing himself was also extremely
nervous with stark girls questioning as
he asked me asking me whether i was
interested in negative material I I
tried I tried to duck this with a
deliberately boring treatise on the duty
of objectivity of the historian which of
course needless to say no ice with
Colonel Stark off at all who then told
us that it was time for lunch and told
us that we could leave all our papers
and bags in the office there and pointed
out where the canteen was and said of
course we had to leave them behind so
that he could actually go through what
we'd done during the course of that
morning was much subtlety there
on the second that will in fact in fact
you've been ready from that from that
afternoon everything was suddenly very
much more relaxed and presumably Colonel
Stark off had found nothing anti Savior
to in our notes from that morning and to
our astonishment we were given a lecture
room to work in completely unsupervised
and we then started on the daily reports
up to twenty pages per day sent by the
political department of the Stalingrad
front to alexander chibok of the chief
commissar of the Red Army in Moscow and
I would say carried away by the material
in fact that I forgot at first three is
supposed to be reading any a couple of
dozen pages out of each of these six
hundred page dossiers each each of these
huge thick dossiers covered just one
month of the battle and once they were
our initial euphoria at getting to the
unvarnished truth because it really was
unvarnished we realized that we had to
be very careful um
Liuba stuck our hand in finger in one of
the permitted passages and every time
you heard footsteps in the corridor she
had to quickly flip it back to one of
the permitted passages and it felt a bit
like cheating and in exam as you might
imagine the page is selected for us
consisted mainly of letters of praise
addressed to Comrade Stalin from
soldiers on the Stalingrad front but the
rest was what I'd almost never dad
believed we'd ever be allowed to see it
was a detailed record day by day without
any propaganda gloss describing not just
any the acts of heroism but also the
extraordinary events this was commissar
speak for desertions self-inflicted
injuries drunkenness of commanders
alcohol poisoning of soldiers retreating
without orders counter-revolutionary
agitation defeatism and all other crimes
punishable by death
and story after story put terrible flesh
on the figure of 13,500
Red Army soldiers executed at Stalingrad
by their own side the problem with the
positive material which was quite
genuine I mean these acts of heroism
were absolutely genuine
was the way that it was written it was
written in the sort of propaganda
cliches which somehow made anything
sound totally unconvincing I was staying
intact with the Canadian political
attache in in his apartment who was a
friend and on the first evening when I
rang my wife in London to tell her that
I could not believe that we'd actually
been allowed near this stuff and
unsupervised a sudden install might has
say signaling to me rather urgently from
across the room to shut up and I opposed
it's easy it was easy to forget in the
in the new capitalist Moscow that some
of the old Soviet habits haven't exactly
um stopped and so in fact even told us
and told me not to say anything about
what has finding when we went out to
dinner one just in a restaurant just had
to be apparently very very careful
anyway Luba and I spent the rest of the
week flipping back and forth on the
handful of permitted pages and the until
we suddenly realized in fact they were
starting to get rather anxious and there
was that curious mixture one found in
Russia that mixed curious mixture sort
of paranoia and naivety it felt very
very disorientating and Colonel Xu
Roisin at the end of the first week
started I think to get suspicious partly
because I obviously was not asking for
enough photocopies because the archives
tichelman shocked I was thought that by
charging a foreign researcher a dollar a
copy for each photocopy you know dude I
know I didn't blame them at all I mean
they God they desperately need the money
but they thought that that would be one
way of controlling the information
because they assumed that some of you
know historians were to idle to copy
everything down themselves in fact one
had to work and Tahlia from sort of
pencil and notebook as I discovered
several years before anyway obviously I
had not asked for enough
photocopies I mean I did ask for some
but obviously hadn't asked for enough to
reassure them and said it finally also
had started to work out that we hadn't
the three word files we've been working
on
I had actually taken has taken us
virtually a week when in fact we were
any supposed to see a few dozen pages
they're even more uneasy on the Monday
morning and sure enough Colonel stock
off reappeared
a few minutes later looking very
unpleasant and there was another
interrogation which was much less
friendly this time after the star coughs
departure Shuba she knew accompanied him
out came back into the office and told
me that they'd have to inspect all my
handwritten notes
I knew perfectly well that it would be
madness to refuse or to try and get on a
high horse in any way instead of course
I agreed immediately and I even offered
to decipher my appalling handwriting
because I guess that they would have to
bring down a an interpreter from the
Ministry of Defence and I mean you know
that would take several hours each day
so I then something said but listen why
don't I give you all the notes at the
end of the end of the week and your
interpreter can work through the whole
lot I mean all the nights I'd taken up
to LEM was still hidden in the flat in
the apartment where I was staying and to
my relief
Shuba xin also seemed relieved and
anyway he agreed that we could work it
out that way
saved that night just in case I started
to work on those pages that I had got
because I found that out of the roughly
at that stage about 80 to 90 pages of
notes I'd taken there any about 40 pages
which could roughly be described as
neutral at first that's one of the very
important tricks actually with Russian
archives he was always work with those
were spying notebooks because then you
can actually tear out the pages without
it showing and just a little tip just in
case you happen to be going off to
Moscow to work in the archives know me
anyway um that I found there is that I
can get more complicated because um it
was quite obvious you know there were
only about to the forty pages left and
so I started copying them into another
notebook and I was wondering how now
like a bulk had the material I was
almost tempted to start composing
letters let it let it let us Comrade
Stalin myself but anyway fortunately
when it came to the end on the last
morning there was a GRU major who
appeared I mean he was obviously joy you
because one could tell he was in uniform
and all the rest of it and a slightly
friendly manner than Stockholm he asked
me was I mr. beaver what are you right
novel anyway it was not hard to guess
which line of approach he was taking and
I said no I was working on I was writing
a work of history how then he asked
since I was taking handwritten notes and
not taking photocopies could I prove the
authenticity of my sources so I replied
that as you would see I was actually
equate iing the form the description the
file and the page number of every single
quotation there if other historians were
dubious about what I'd written and they
had a precise reference for checking
this of course was not a terribly
popular answer and he spent the whole of
the morning of them back of the room
going through all of the notebooks and
then the interesting thing was that
another interpreter was brought in in
the afternoon also to check but I don't
know perhaps even also to check on his
work finally we were given we were given
the all clear and funny enough that ship
Colonel Shuba she knew I liked I liked a
lot in fact he had a good we had a good
sense of humor when he wasn't being
nervous was clearly clearly relieved and
I felt sort of secretly elated despite
really had passed my exam but when I got
back to the apartment
my host warned me that there was a very
small risk that the military authorities
might suddenly have second thoughts and
I might be searched at the airport and
they might confiscate all my notes so he
took me into the Canadian embassy the
following morning just before my flight
and we fed and fed copied every page to
leave a spare copy just in case but in
the event there was no problem and so
ended my only brush really with the
world of John Locke era
I returned to the rational check
archives again over the last three years
for research on the fall of Berlin and I
regret to say that however much
President Putin makes friends with
Western leaders some of the archives are
definitely less open than they were the
atmosphere and political rhetoric in
Russia as the last lot of elections
underlined seems to hark back yearning
the apparent certainties of the past
although the control of access to
archives has been getting tighter they
have of course been fluctuations I mean
nothing is sort of entirely in one
direction and in fact this was during
the Kosovo crisis when I was applying to
get back into the ministry defense
archives and I didn't I didn't actually
dare believe that with the tensions as a
result of the conservative or crisis
were murder we would ever actually get
back into podolsk but eventually we were
allowed back in that September and
Colonel Juba she now the director in
fact was extremely affable and much more
relaxed than all the rest of it but I
knew that not much had changed except
presentation when he said um we would
like to see ourselves in a way as the
co-authors of your book well you can
imagine mice mice behind that idea but
anyway one of his colleagues then said
that they would like to see how I'd made
use of the material from the archive in
in the book on Stalingrad anyway thank
goodness my Russian publishers had taken
a very very long time translating the
book and it hadn't yet appeared in
Russia which is a huge stroke of luck so
I replied you know but soon you'll be
able to read it in Russian um and they
they were rather irritated by that they
said but haven't you got a copy of the
English or even the German Edition with
your you know our translators could read
it and well I could say was a rather
pathetic layer how silly of me and I'll
send you a copy when I get back to
England or something like that
then there wasn't very much they could
actually do about that fortunately but
this time Luba and I were allocated a
supervisor named Ella who was supposed
to stay with us the whole time to make
sure that we did not look at any pages
outside the allotted ones same system as
before but as I say this time permanent
watchdog and for the first two days we
went through just the official passages
and all all very predictable well Allah
yawned her way through crossword puzzles
which was sort of a new invention or a
new import rather from from the West and
we wondered how on earth we might get
rid of her Luba Luba even wizard
whispered to me rather naughtily that I
should give her a box of chocolates
laced with laxatives luckily for us
luckily for us our watchdog became bored
of her crossword puzzles after a couple
of days and then she started to play a
version of grandmother's footsteps I
didn't with him even had that same sort
of game of creeping up on somebody and
having to freeze or whatever but anyway
she started playing this a couple of
times by leaving us alone for a few
minutes and then tiptoeing back up the
corridor and suddenly opening the door
to see if we look guilty
and eventually she went shopping because
from the window of the archive where we
were working I suddenly saw her going
out of them going out of the main gate
and say from then on i sat facing facing
the window watching for her return while
Luba worked as fast as possible through
the sort of forbidden forbidden
materialised that they're taking
dictation and that worked very well for
the next few days but then I'm afraid
one afternoon my octoroon come back she
must have slipped back in another way or
I'd sort of just missed her and she
caught us in the act but mercifully not
long before when Luber had gone off gone
off to the restroom I'd actually ripped
out again from my trusty wire bound knit
books had ripped out the sort of illicit
passages and stuffed them in my trouser
pocket and that hadn't been very long
before so when 'allah demanded that I
hand over all of the
notebooks Luber exact went white
thinking god we've really been caught
out but I wasn't able to signal to our
in fact that everything was alright but
what is striking is that when the
notebooks because we're ia then again
demanded every single notebook should be
handed over when all the notebooks were
handed back Allah who in fact I think
was quite senior um tore out pages in
front of me and just ripped them up even
though these came from the permitted
passages and what was rather significant
was them was that they were only listed
there allegations of rape made against
officers of the red army and she said
very angrily you can write that any
culprits fun guilty but punished well
this we knew already too well from other
sources both Soviet and German was the
opposite of the truth the lesson really
is that there's no point becoming
frustrated over what you cannot get at
in thus in the Russian archives you
simply have to keep going for everything
you can get a chance to see sadly as I
was saying the half-open window is
closing again despite the reproach more
last drm swedish historian went away
started the year before the end of the
year before swedish historian rang me to
ask whether i had heard the DFS be the
successor to the KGB was now checking
every single archive to find out which
files had been taken out by foreign
historians and what they contained and a
few months ago in fact a Russian expert
at Bristol University in the United
Kingdom who's working in Moscow on her
next book rang me to say that all this
information on foreign researchers has
now been centralized and is in fact all
on come along computers in these
archives but the striking thing as I say
is that none of these archives have a
computer for their catalogs but they
have a computer purely to record what
the foreign historians are taking out
which is a bit rather a depressing
rather a depressing development anyway
the Battle for Berlin in April and the
beginning of May 1945 was the long
predicted climax of the war on the
Eastern Front
but once again thousands died for vain
symbols on
besides to read army divisions were
thrown against that massive and well
defended building the Reichstag to raise
the red banner of victory and on the
German side Hitler a devotee of the
movies must have visualized his own
gutter damn wrong in Berlin and brave
amid blazing monuments crashing down
in fact Albert Speer agreed with Hitler
during their very last meeting in the
bunker that the pool of BAFTAs garden
didn't have quite the same ring as the
pool of Berlin war between the two
totalitarian states of Nazi Germany and
the Soviet Union were not just a war of
ideologies it was also a war between two
monstrous vanities but the point of
writing a new book on such well-known
subject was not to focus just on the
leaders and the commanders it had to
rediscover the experience of the
individual caught up in this terrifying
and mad Malstrom and once again I did
not just want the headquarter war
Diaries and logs but also the letters
home from ordinary soldiers private
Diaries reports of prisoner
interrogations and so on in the case of
Stalingrad there were huge numbers of
letters to choose from that was not the
case arrow of the Berlin the German Feld
post as well as the internal mail had
collapsed but fortunately many people
especially women in Berlin realized that
they were living through one of the key
moments in history and they kept a minut
record of events in private Diaries and
several of these Diaries are truly
outstanding the downfall in Berlin
itself produced a crescendo of insanity
and grotesque images one staff officer
in the who'd been in the bunker
described to me the atmosphere as a
mixture of hysteria and resignation
another general Freitag von Loring - who
was there almost until the very end
recounted how SS officers and Nazi
leaders spent their time discussing the
best way to commit suicide poison or a
bullet through the head Hitler in fact
was handing out cyanide capsules at the
end as if they were sweets to be stuck
during takeoff for the next world
Hitler's dementia came from a
persecution complex and the transcending
delusion that he was the incarnation of
Germany the defeated German people did
not deserve to survive him therefore
they too should die one visitor
remembered a never ending monologue in
his loud rasping voice there was of ours
on the table beside them and he had the
strange feeling that even if he were to
smash the vars over the Fury's head the
voice would continue by itself as if
detached the sense of unreality pervaded
everything even the Fuehrer Adama
wronged itself with Hitler and his new
bride dressed in black had its elements
of grotesque farce
Hitler's valet ling'er managed to steal
his master's watch as they bundled his
corpse up in a gray army blanket and
when the two bodies were doused in
petrol and set on fire in the Reich
Chancellery garden one of the SS guards
who had been drinking heavily in the
canteen up in the right Chancellery
rushed downstairs and called to the SS
to left NIST the Chiefs on fire do you
want to come and have a look this
telephonist from the SS lodged under
Adolf Hitler is called a Rochus Misch
and he's still alive
and it was very strange sitting in his
little parlour in Berlin drinking tea as
he proudly showed us the album full of
photographs he'd taken of Hitler playing
with blondie his German Shepherd dog at
the Bull Schanzer headquarters in East
Prussia
unfortunately raucous mush did not have
his camera with him in the bunker and my
knowledge in fact any I think any one
photograph was taken in it during those
last days the greatest drama continued
but in a different way after the Reich
Chancellery was captured by the Red Army
on the 2nd of May in 1945 and a smash
detachment under general Vardis took
over the bunker
Stalin urgently wanted to know what had
become of Hitler smash Soviet
counterintelligence hadn't heard from
surrendering German generals and
officials that the Nazi leader had
committed suicide but nobody could find
the body eventually it was discovered by
SMERSH operatives on the 5th of May
buried in a shallow hole along with the
body of
ever Brown and his adored dog blondi but
Stalin did not want anyone to know not
only did he use this as an opportunity
for accusing the Americans of having
hidden Hitler in Bavaria he also wanted
to put pressure on his own army
commanders he rang marshal Zhukov on two
occasions to taunt him with the supposed
failure to find Hitler when he Stalin
knew all the time the SMERSH was
carrying out its own autopsy on the body
this may beggar belief but I promise you
it is true marshal Zhukov the commander
in chief in Berlin did not discover for
twenty years
not until 1965 that Hitler's body had
been found this was all part of the
Byzantine world of Stalinist politics
Stalin feared the popularity of marshal
Zhukov and later had him accused of
Bonaparte ISM before the great victory
in fact before the great victory parade
scheduled to take place on Red Square on
the 24th of June Stalin summoned Zhukov
he told him that he was to take the
parade according to Russian tradition
mounted on horseback
Zhukov with great circumspection replied
that surely Comrade Stalin as
commander-in-chief should have the art
honor I'm too old you are younger you
take it on saying goodbye Stalin
tôchuken
to use an Arab stallion which marshal
budyonny would show him the next day
Zhukov went to the central air field to
watch drill rehearsals for the parade
there he met Stalin's son Vasily who was
bit of a playboy in the Air Force who
said to him I'm telling you this is a
big secret father had himself been
preparing to take the victory parade but
a strange incident took place three days
ago the horse voted in the menage
because he did not use his Spurs very
cleverly father caught hold of the mane
and tried to stay in the saddle that did
not manage and fell as he fell he
injured his children head when he stood
up he spat and said let drew cough take
the parade
he's an old cavalry man and which horse
was your father we were riding sugar
fast a white Arab stallion the one which
sought to ride but I beg you not to
mention a word of this shook off thanks
here
and in the next few days in few days
remaining he didn't waste a single
opportunity to get back into the saddle
and master than this particular horse in
the meantime Hitler's corpse had been
examined in every detail the most
certain means of verification were the
teeth in fact in specifically the
bridgework the assistant to Hitler's
dentist had been tracked down in Berlin
and brought in to identify the jaws
which had been removed from the skull
and when were in Moscow we interviewed
yelena raiskaya was the interpreter in
the SMERSH detachment in the right
Chancellery and she told us how on the
evening of the 8th of May when all the
Soviet troops were going wild in
celebration at the victory and the
announcement of a victory which was
coming up she was given a satin lined
red box by her boss the sort used for
cheap jewelry she described it inside
where Hitler's two jaws remove moved
during the secret autopsy and she was
warned by her SMERSH superior that if
they were lost she would answer with her
head a razor of skaia was entrusted with
his vital artifacts because as a woman
she was less likely to get drunk and
lose them during the course of that
evening and so she spent that particular
night the night of the victory parade
and victory celebrations with the Red
Box tucked clamped under her left arm
while she poured drinks for her smash
comrades with the right
Anjelica von hase my German research
researcher and I also had some fairly
ghoulish experiences the BBC has been
had been filming me
researching the book over the last two
and a half years and when I mentioned
that there was this extraordinary
gravedigger called Gareth Aram whom I
heard about the director of the film was
intrigued and in the end we met him we
met up with him in the forests near
Hobart just south of Berlin where some
50,000 Germans were massacred in the
last major battle on European soil
altogether you may be interested to know
about a thousand corpses a year are
still being discovered in Iran Berlin
and the province of brandenburg from the
fighting in 1945
many have been dug up during
construction work in the city itself for
the vast majority in the area southeast
of Berlin have been unearthed by
treasure hunters with metal detectors
most of them are former East Germans
desperately trying to make some extra
money searching for medals and helmets
and other not seen artifacts to sell in
street market apparently in some places
you can find helmets for sale with a
skull still inside and the local women
in charge as a huge war cemetery at
Harbor have on occasion had to chase
these men with metal detectors away from
the graves in the cemetery as they try
to rob them
garol ram who's a dedicated local
historian of the battle as well as an
undertaker is very very different he
collects up any skeletons he finds and
takes them to the cemetery at how about
for proper reburial in one shallow grave
behind beside the berlin dresden
autobahn guerra Raman discovered the
Enigma encryption machine of the 9th
army the rhine tommy was their army
escaping from from the oder during the
Battle of Berlin through these forests
and by that stage of the war with
communications broken down it was a
useless object but still there any a few
enigma machines left in the world it so
happened that on the day we joined him
men searching for artifacts with metal
detectors in the forest had dumped a
couple of rubbish bags containing half a
dozen skeletons outside the gate Saigal
drum set to work sorting them out and
while doing this he gave me a
masterclass passing me a skull and
explaining how you could tell
immediately if it was a Soviet or a
German soldier the Russians who had no
sweets to eat possess much healthier
teeth but their teeth were stained with
black macaca tobacco the Germans on the
other had on the other hand had
magnesium fillings and also showed signs
of vitamin deficiency which produced
rough patches on the teeth as you might
imagine it was a strange sensation
handing the skulls the soldiers killed
during the battle and an even stranger
feeling arose when we managed to trace
the family of another soldier who
skeleton girl Ram dug up while we were
filming out in the forest we found his
dog tag among the personal items which
emerge from the sandy soil under these
tall pine trees and funny enough amongst
his kit there also emerged near less
than four combs he'd belonged to the
Luftwaffe Aflac artillery attached to
the 9th army and although the dog tag
bore no name it had details which might
identify him said the BBC researcher
passed it to their mocked Dean Stella in
Berlin and six months later we heard
that his name was cut cowl ish and that
his family had been contacted on our
next trip to Berlin we went to see his
daughter
now just in her 60s and she showed us
the photographs she had of him and it
was very unsettling to gaze at the man
whose car light held in the forest and I
couldn't help noticing the beautifully
neat fur hair and thinking of the four
combs in his pack which had emerged from
the soil other research trips also
produced strange experiences last spring
with Luba again we went to Georgia with
the BBC to interview more veterans who'd
taken part in the Battle for Berlin one
of the reasons for getting to Georgia is
in fact they live rather a lot longer in
Georgia than they do in in in Russia
itself but the most extraordinary
character we encountered was Stalin's
grandson Yevgeny juga filly we talked to
him in Stalin's birthplace in the town
of gory now a memorial to Stalin himself
barrier in fact is a tribute to his
chief had raised about a quarter of the
of the town in 1951 all around the great
helmsman's birthplace which is as to
Rome Havel and he created a huge ma
museum there and erected a Stalinist
oriental marble Poznan over this heady
of Holies which is still a place of
pilgrimage the grandson bears a striking
resemblance to the Generalissimo and he
cultivates the look as far as he can go
did win any Stalin look-alike
competition with a swept back hair the
moustache
yellow teeth and even the way he holds
his cigarette when the cameras began to
row and we started to talk about him
talk to him he made the most
extraordinary boast when I asked him
about the purchase of 1937 everyone goes
on about those so-called purchase he
replied but what about the crimes over
the previous thirty years it was a quite
an interesting statement my grandfather
did what the country wanted he rarely
sorted out the Jews Luba who was half
Jewish turned to me and said instead an
aunt in English Anthony can I tell him
what I think of him I said please they
were not not while the cameras are
really and just he just keep him talking
it was it was fascinating the way he
openly echoed the approach of the Nazi
ideologist claiming that Bolshevism was
entirely dominated by the Jews they were
almost all Jews regretfully went on just
think what the Israelis would say if
their cabinet was dominated by Arabs
well that's what it was like for us
until my grandfather put an end to it
well you can imagine one was left so
rather rather speechless to that well
anyway afterwards well yeah any Jew gosh
video or Stalin or whatever you want to
call him stood on the steps to be
photographed with groups of
schoolchildren in fact one group of
schoolchildren after another Luba and I
went to inspect Stalin's vibe only coach
in fact it was the one in which he
travelled to Potsdam and also to Yalta
Stalin always insisted on choosing
places where he could go by train
because he was terrified of flying and
he claimed that he was ill at the
beginning of 1945 and insisted that
Churchill and Roosevelt who was already
extremely ill and close to death should
fly all the way to the Crimea
anyway this wagon league coach is green
with love Art Nouveau fittings from its
Zara's construction and as we were
sharing Stalin's sleeping quarters the
guide gestured this woman guide gestured
the adjoining bathroom saying in a
reverential voice and this is where
Comrade Stalin performed his hygienic
functions Luba collapsed in giggles
which was there
anyway the table was afterwards we we
had to have lunch with Jewish Willy and
he called for vodka and insisted on
making one test after another these
followed the accepted pattern which we'd
found with all Soviet veterans the first
was to international peace the second
was to the wartime alliance between the
Soviet Union and the United States and
Great Britain the third was to the
ladies but then to my horror he insisted
on drinking to the Generalissimo Luba
refused to raise her glass but I am
forced to confess that out of British
politeness that masquerade for moral
cowardice I
I raised my glass to avoid a scene and
it's the only time I've ever drunk to a
mass-murderer Luba had remarked me at
one point in Moscow I think we deserved
darlin I felt bound to disagree if any
because one can never say that a whole
people deserved an appalling leader it
is in any case one of the terrible
chicken-and-egg questions of history
whether a leader like Hitler or Stalin
of a product of our country's history or
the shaper or both on many occasions
I've been asked who was the greater
criminal Hitler Stalin Stalin and it's
an interesting philosophical question
Stalin was almost certainly responsible
for more deaths
especially those his own countrymen and
women but chemins day which crime is
worse racial genocide or political
genocide Andrei Sakharov the great
scientist and saviour dissident once
observed that although Stalin killed
more people Hitler had to be defeated
first and he was undoubtedly right a
Nazi victory over the Soviet Union in
1941 would have been so terrible that
there is no other answer
in fact the mass starvation and
enslavement which the knots his plan for
the population of the occupied
territories up to the Archangel
Astrakhan line simply does not bear
thinking about
after years of Soviet propaganda it is
very hard for Russians to face the
implications of their country's past
horrors it means questioning seventy
years of terrible sacrifice and
countless millions of wasted lives
for Russians therefore it is far more
difficult to face it and to reexamine in
that sort of history than the Germans
faced with a 12-year aberration in a way
the Soviet victory in 1945 makes it even
harder to reexamine after accusing me of
Lies slander and blasphemy against the
Red Army the Russian ambassador in
London explained to me privately later
why his country found it hard to
question the past and when you must
understand that the victory is sacred
yes but in reality it was the vast human
sacrifice which made it sacred this is
why Russians have such trouble with the
subject and not just Stalinist dinosaurs
even the most antecedent and
anti-militarist of them do not find it
easy for example Luba had some difficult
moments in the Moscow archives as we
worked together the hardest especially
for her came about in the old Marxist
Leninist Leninist Institute we were
working through the reports sent to the
political Department the Red Army glove
porker to find them here in the party
archive in fact was indeed fortunate
because these and similar documents are
unobtainable out at Podolski at the
ministry defence central archive where
they're still classified a secret one
thick dossier dealt with the subject of
the Red Army in fact one of several was
dealing with the subject of the Red Army
and rape in Germany in 1945 and Luba was
becoming increasingly uneasy and when I
muttered something at one point her
reaction was based aggressive and
defensive at the same time well Antony
I'm sorry she said but I refuse to feel
sorry for those German with German women
who were raped they must have encouraged
their men to invade the Soviet Union do
what they did I avoided getting into any
sort of argument with her because I knew
how difficult it was during the research
on Stalingrad at one point she'd said
with any of the trace of a joke helping
you get this material almost makes me
feel like a traitor to the motherland
but then a few days later in the same
archive we came across in a totally
different section we came across a very
detailed report to the Central Committee
of the constable of the communist youth
from the deputy chief of the political
apartment of the 1st Ukrainian front
this gave chapter and verse detailing
the widespread rape of Russian and
especially Ukrainian girls and women
deported by the Vermont to Germany for
slave labor these young women seemed to
have been around 17 to 25 had been
praying for liberation from our slavery
by the Red Army but when they found
their disbelief in horror the day in
fact were treated in exactly the same as
the German women by the Red Army
soldiers general as the gang cough cited
example after example in his report
including groups of officers and
soldiers up to sixty is strong most of
them drunk charging into the dormitories
where the liberated Soviet girls were
quartered and raping them he also
recounted the words of the 18-year old
ever stool my father and two brothers
went to the Red Army at the beginning of
the war she stated soon after the
Germans invaded and I was taken to
Germany by force I worked in a factory
here I cried and waited for the day of
liberation soon the Red Army came and
the soldiers dishonored me I cried until
the senior officer that my brothers were
fighting for our country yet he beat me
and raped me it would have been better
if he had killed me but perhaps it is
the final remarks in generals Ngong
coughs report which is so shocking all
this provides fertile ground from
healthy and negative moods to grow among
the liberated Soviet citizens he read it
causes discontent and mistrust for their
return to their mother country yet there
is no suggestion in the gang coughs
report that the discipline in the Red
Army should be tightened he's simply
urged but measures on improving
political and cultural work with
repatriated Soviet citizens should be
stepped up that is to say that these
young women should be brainwashed or
coerced into saying nothing about their
negative impressions of the Red Army
when they returned to the Soviet Union
this was far worse than anything that I
had imagined Luba was shaken to the core
we return to the apartment which she
shares with her mother Galya in North
Moscow and where I stay when everyone
and and the next day I mean Lewis helps
that she's been missed that night
talking to her mother and the next day I
was able to get Galya on her own because
I too felt a desperate need to
understand because it was very hard to
put this into her into the context of
revenge which is the way that it's
always been portrayed the two million
women who German women who are estimated
to have been raped in the attack on
Germany in 1945 um anyway I wanted to
talk to Galya because I've always had a
huge respect for her honesty and
intelligence she was a brilliant
scientist who funny enough won the
Stalin prize for chemistry and having
lived through the post-war terror she
was fascinated by everything that we
were finding in the archives on the odd
day when Galya worked with me in an
archive to give Luber a break she was so
interested in every document that it's
led down the work considerably but
Anthony this is so interesting she would
keep staring and I'd had to reply yes
Galya but you know we've we've got to
get on it's not what we're after anyway
Galya started to point me in what I
think is the right direction and you
have to understand peasant life in
Russia she said she talked about the
brutal promiscuity of a village life
based before and after the Revolution
curiously this went hand in hand with a
terrible sexual ignorance which was made
far worse in Stalinist times when all
forms of sex education were forbidden
and there are some interesting papers by
Russian psychologists on the subject all
human emotions of love and desire had to
be subjected and re channeled during the
1930s
into love for the party and above all
for Comrade Stalin it was all part of
the campaign to D individualize the
individual but Galya also argued that
all armies are the same I was not
entirely convinced by this in the
conquest of Germany it were marked
differences in the way different
national armies had behaved and treated
women as the Western Allies it appears
certainly appears that the French army
was the worst by a long way
most notoriously the sack of Stuttgart
included in many cases raped by French
colonial
from North Africa American troops it
must be said I didn't need to because
they had cartons of cigarettes and tins
of food to offer but that's how some say
also said that the British Army was the
best in purely Bijoux to the NCO system
but with corporal some platoon sergeants
keeping a close eye on them on their men
others tried to claim that it was the
bromide in the tea but I'm not sure what
the case is
but whatever whatever the situation I
realized with considerable unease as a
man that was definitely an underlying
truth in what Galia said in the past I'd
certainly dismissed out of hand
the finished feminist idea that all men
are potential rapists but now I
certainly after all of the material we'd
been through I certainly had to
acknowledge the perhaps most men could
be potential rapists in certain extreme
circumstances of chaos and collapse
above all if they have a gun and there
is no threat of retribution the trouble
with the Red Army and this seems
astonishing when one thinks that the
extreme controls of Soviet Stalinist
civilian society was the degree of
indiscipline Red Army soldiers
especially when they discovered a source
of alcohol were wildly if not totally
uncontrollable it was brave if not
foolhardy for an officer to try to stop
drunken soldiers from raping or looting
in fact any attempt to exert authority
was likely to be met with a burst of
submachine gun firm the only way to
shoot was to shoot a man on the spot
before he had a chance to react I mean
in the book I recount have a general
shot a left hand who'd lined up his
mentor raper German woman one after
another and in Berlin for example I'd
heard how a Russian soldier who was
assaulting a German girl in the entrance
to a new barn stationed her friend
dashed out into the street to find help
and found a Russian leftenant and
dragged him back to help save her friend
and Russian left on had just grabbed the
soldier by the throat pushed his head
back against the wall and blew his
brains out with the pistol
of course the poor girl who had been
attacked was completely spattered with
his brains but these cases of officers
exerting discipline appear to be few and
far between it was in fact very little
incentive for them to intervene because
some officers who tried to control her
men found themselves denounced to SMERSH
as enemies of the people left cop
earlier for friend of Solzhenitsyn was
arrested for bourgeois humanism in other
words the crime of pity towards the
enemy Coppola was also shot by a young
woman officer making jokes about the
rapes and the playwright Agron
incarnated in his diary that one of his
women officers fully justified the rape
of German women in Berlin some German
women and recorded have Soviet service
women watched them being raped and loved
this pitiless attitude has not entirely
disappeared a couple of months ago a
Russian woman interpreter brought in by
the BBC to transcribe or to check the
transcription of the interviews in the
time much film made about the book also
read the memories of German women
describing their experiences she was
outraged if they were raped she said
then it was because they wanted it so
things have not advanced as you might
imagine the attitudes of relative all
Russian soldiers have certainly not
developed very much and the respect for
the individual and human life has not
greatly changed in fact the favorite
dinner party anecdote of general Libet
who was killed you may have seen
recently in a helicopter crash in
Siberia gives a good idea this was a
country by a British diplomat in Moscow
who'd been now Lebed used to describe
how when you'd arrived as governor of
Krasnoyarsk his first act had been to
invite round the local military
commander and he asked him what his
problems were well this general general
is supposed to have replied it's the
weather during the last winter about a
dozen conscripts committed suicide and
the ground was so frozen we weren't able
to bury their bodies so as soon as the
fall came I had all the conscripts at
digging graves that we wouldn't be
caught out the next winter and do you
know what happened
no sale ever what did happen
18 of them deserted the next morning I
mean that gives you an idea of Russian
sense of humor and it sort of sums up
the attitude towards sort of the
individual and human life attitudes to
the past in Germany on the other hand
have now reached a new stage which is
very interesting in the last few months
things have started to evolve in an
important way
a feeling of normal easier more
normalization has started many if not
most Germans I started sorry I starting
to take a different view of the end of
the Second World War they feel that at
last it's become acceptable to portray
Germans especially the civilians as
victims alongside the other victims of
the Nazis this has been partly sparked
by günter grass this new novel in Krebs
gang grass resolute anti-nazi right
they're famous for his great novel the
tin drum focuses in this new book on the
fate of refugees from East and West
Prussia in the early part of 1945 the
book revolves around the sinking by a
Soviet submarine of the liner film
Gustav in the Baltic over 7,000 refugees
were drowned in the icy waters of the
Pomeranian coast just thinking
comparison to the Titanic the fact that
this took place on the 30th of January
the 12th anniversary of Hitler's
assumption of power makes the symbolism
all the more striking it is of course
quite right but the terrible suffering
of German civilians should be
acknowledged at long last it is also
right that Germany should be allowed to
lay down the but a veil should be drawn
over the horrors of the past must also
not underestimate the perils involved if
the process of normalization is taken
too far many Germans are now trying to
buy back their ancestral lands in
Silesia and Pomerania the land is very
cheap and they're pretty rich punished
territory since 1945 the poles and also
the Czechs are understandably uneasy at
the idea there's a political movement
might develop in Germany demanding the
revision of borders or the restitution
of property to the descendants of those
refugees forced out in 1945 if the
European Union is to expand eastwards to
include Poland and the Czech Republic
then the question must be resolved
firmly and clearly one of the most
dangerous paradoxes that the whole
European ideal has also surged up in the
last few weeks as we've seen in the
French presidential elections with lepen
and in the emergence of the far-right
even in Holland a country famed for its
liberalism the assassination of pim
fortuyn of course brings it all into
even sharper focus whether all this is
coincidental or not we cannot tell yet
but I suspect that there is a connection
the main impetus for the German emphasis
on closer European unity is based in my
view on a fundamental confusion of cause
and effect
the genuine horror quite genuine of
another war in Europe has inspired
German politicians to argue that any
closer integration can prevent another
conflict but this totally fails to
recognize the risk that the European
solution might produce exactly the
opposite of what it is setting out to
achieve to try to denational eyes to try
to take away the nationalist problem
from Europe in fact is only exacerbating
it to conclude I'd like to re-emphasize
how vital it is to understand the end of
the Second World War in Europe not
because it was the start of the Cold War
but because the problems suspicions and
resentments created them have reeling
the collapse of communism the Cold War
while suppressing nationalist conflicts
and any 50 years had in fact acted
rather like a straightjacket while doing
nothing to resolve them wars between
states above all in Western Europe a
must flit a thing of the past
but old ethnic resentments and feelings
of unease are not in fact any argument
attempt to argue that only further
European integration can solve the
problem is to say the least
misguided
thank you very much
and now if anybody has any question hey
David Rockefeller PN war anyways try out
some more air as you bits in novel form
you don't fit us perfect Stalingrad
sorry haven't read it I I can't I have
net I have therefore no opinion okay
unfortunately yes give it I was just
encouraged by your final comments the
happy immunity of United Kingdom and to
what is going on as you have any
personal believes as to whether Britain
should lessen or or increased distance
between itself and the continent well I
think one of the problems is I mean the
general idea of European unification is
it's great I'm not it's not a question
of being against that
the trouble is human society can only
adapt to change at a certain rate if you
try to accelerate that change
particularly by sort of social
engineering you are actually creating
problems in the future and hatred and
resentment and one of the great
fallacies of the European experiment I
think - any way of calling it is the
idea that you go in for economic unity
first and then you rapidly pull in
political unity alongside it that is not
a very I of the thought of very good
where's any economists will tell you and
anybody who doubts it is sort of accused
of sort of you know you're you're not a
European so once once now got getting a
new new definition of sort of patriotism
I'm afraid in M frayed in Europe and
it's quite interesting how it's going to
turn out I think that the one of the
main problems is over the last ten to
fifteen years partly as a result of the
end of the Cold War and the Cold War
kept change to a minimum I mean from 45
to 85 particularly in Britain there was
remarkably little social change and then
suddenly everything started to change at
the same time there was geopolitical
change technological change social
change the structure of companies
started to change there's the flattening
out process and all the rest of it and
it was a hell of a lot to people for
people to absorb I mean you know for the
young that might have been
very very exciting at that particular
time obviously for the middle age and
particularly for the elderly it was very
much more alarming and to have a
political process within Europe at the
same time sort of forced on top I think
is actually sort of expecting a bit too
much in too short a space of time but we
will see we will see yes tension between
so-called martial : marshal Konev was
not a very attractive personality it
must be said I think even even his
colleagues found him a pretty terrifying
prospect he the real reason there for
the rivalry between them wasn't a lien
inspired by Stalin partly er a general
policy of divide and rule but it was
true that he was so desperate to get to
Berlin before the Allies particularly
before the Americans that he were you
that this was the best way to put
pressure because if you get pressure on
that commander he will be threatening on
down the line I mean there's a marvelous
example if you like of save yet alpha
male behavior is the way that our
military commander will grab the
telephone stand up to bellow into the
telephone you will never do it sitting
down he has to stand up to bellow into
the telephone and that was very much
sort of the pressure that was being put
down the line in that way the
significant age if you will remember I
think it was the 7th of March the bridge
at Remagen now I don't think that any
American Historians that I've noticed I
may well be wrong on this has picked up
on the fact that on the 8th of March
marshal Zhukov was summoned immediately
by aeroplanes from commanding an
operation in the pomeranian operation
back to Moscow by Stalin Stalin wanted
action on Berlin immediately Stalin had
seen in the moment that the Americans
have managed to breach the Rhine in that
way that their advancement Berlin was
like to be very very rapid so the
planning was in fact carried I'd
extremely rapidly because they had all
of these different armies in Pomerania
right into West Prussia
crash that last part their right flank
and they thought they had much more time
because they thought the Americans
really would be held up for much longer
on the Rhine so everything had to be
pushed back in a hurry and the pressure
was actually put on at that meeting on
the 1st of April when Konya and Zhukov
were given their final instructions on
the operation before they flew back and
I think it's quite striking that that
particular afternoon immediately a day
had left
Stalin turned to the signals SCAF - five
- sent to him by General Eisenhower
pointing out or detailing exactly what
Allied policy was going to be and that
they weren't interested in Berlin and
that they were going to be our dancing
into the center and then Stalin sent
back his reply to Eisenhower that
evening having just ordered the attack
with 2.5 million men upon Berlin to say
that we're any gain to send second-rate
troops against Berlin our real thrust is
going to be again in the centre talk
about hoodwinking or pulling the wool
over his eyes and he said and also we
are not going to be moving until the
middle of May well in fact he'd given
orders that morning that they were to be
moving by the 16th of April one month
earlier Eisenhower
I think I'd it's a very one can go on
debating it's one of the what ifs of
history I think actually made the right
decision for totally the wrong reasons
the point is that Stalin a was obsessed
with Berlin for symbolic reasons the Red
Army deserved it after all of the
suffering in the Soviet Union and all
arrested fact that is certainly logical
but there was one very important
material incentive and that was the
uranium in the physics particularly the
physics laboratory at of the Kaiser
Wilhelm Institute for physique and dalam
and the remember of this particular
stage with the Manhattan Project and the
Soviet spies inside the Manhattan
Project
the Soviet operation Borodino was trying
to replicate all the work being done as
the information came through by the spy
line
and but the one thing they did not have
was uranium so it wasn't a question of
trying to pinch the Germans scientists
or anything like that though they did
need the German scientists for
processing the uranium but they did not
have any uranium at that stage so that I
think was one of the key key elements in
the decision it certainly wasn't the
only one but it was certainly a key one
as we found in these documents which are
still difficult to get out of these
documents between barrier and Stalin on
the whole question and what they got at
out of dalam and why it had to be done
so quickly because all of that area was
going to be part of the American zone
and we've got to strip it out
before the Americans even know what's in
there so yes I think there was a very
good reason for the rivalry in that
particular case but it was mainly
Stalinist orientated yes I've always
thought that there was a deal cut
between the Allies particularly the US
and Russia to let the Russians in first
hell backpack and so on but you're
saying now apparently here says that
that's not the case there was no it was
not a formal deal I think that
Eisenhower had as he describes it and
said you know Bradley as well they felt
almost that bewbs Stalin had a right to
Berlin of which you know there's a you
know there is obviously are not argument
for that there's also a completely false
argument about casualties Bradley
because in fact the other generals were
all wanting to go for Berlin I mean as
you as you know from the DES particular
accounts and the arguments afterwards
Bradley though persuaded Eisenhower I
think the guys in had didn't want much
need much persuasion I think he actually
was longing to find more arguments for
not going Bradley said he reckoned it
would cost 100,000 casualties well I
mean that actually even I think Bradley
afterwards Britain acknowledged that
that was exaggeration
but I mean we interviewed the chief of
staff of the 12th army
Colonel height helm who's still alive is
in his 90s of the 12th army facing the
Americans on the Elbe and his operations
officer Colonel Humboldt von de Croydon
I think and you know they said listen we
could not understand why the Americans
didn't move
we were longing for them to come through
I mean the west of Berlin the window SS
unit said the ver mark was just longing
to surrender to the Americans they
wanted the Americans to get to Berlin
before the Russians any reason for
fighting on was to hold the Russians off
well they got out as many people and
hoped as I said for the Americans to get
through so the whole question of
casualties was either a complete
misunderstanding or was basically an
excuse for not going for Berlin it's
true Eisenhower was not interested in
the political aftermath of the war I
think he implicitly recognized later
he'd been wrong but whether Churchill
was right or not whether one could have
taken Berlin and used it as leverage to
Stalin to have behaved better over
Poland is a different matter
I didn't blink actually I think
Churchill was wrong there I think that
Stalin was so determined that he was
going to have Poland and do entirely
what he thought was right at Yalta he
was trying to signal to Churchill that
Poland was an extension of the
percentage agreement he kept on
referring to Greece ie
part of the percentage agreement which
was Greece we then we the Soviets were
not interfering Greece he also made the
point that they hadn't tried to stir up
the French Communist Party behind
British and American lines therefore the
British and the Americans should not
interfere over Poland whatsoever and
Stalin I think was genuinely outraged
because he thought the message have got
through but it hadn't got through at all
I'm afraid neither Churchill nor
Roosevelt were taking very much in at
that particular stage but anyway to get
back to the final point why I think
Eisenhower probably was right for the
wrong reasons was that Stalin was so
determined to get Berlin that the may
well have been if American
forces had pushed forward but may well
have been attacks on them by red army
aviation or artillery if they were in
within range and then Starling would
have blend that as a mistaken Talia the
fault of the Americans for having
charged in without warning us and all
the rest of it so he'd have come up with
all of these particular reasons but I
think really would have been might well
have been clashes so as I say I think
that Eisenhower was probably right for
the wrong reasons
just the back now I even have a start in
this country the assessing Eisenhower's
presidency and his general personality
intelligence it is no longer thought
that he was naive when they disagree
with me but the general feeling is that
many differences I know what I Eva
thought I would suggest that a decision
not to go further was very conscious
whether had to be within 50 pounds of
25,000 or hundred right can be debated
both ways
I know a new that is not on the occupied
France
Weston so why should he go on after all
in in our practice um well I agree it's
certainly one of those areas of one of
the waters of his history on Ole Miss
counterfactual history what would have
happened if he had gone and you know was
it the right decision and I wouldn't
really you know try and take it very
much further but I do think there that
he was certainly was naive in the way
that he gave all the information to
Stalin because like Roosevelt he felt we
can do business with Stalin if we tell
him all our plans and then you know
he'll treat us right well that certainly
wasn't the case
Stalin completely hoodwinked him so I'm
afraid I think Eisenhower was naive on
that particular spot and he actually as
good as admitted it in his memoirs later
while sort of half justifying himself
yes worried about the German officials
with government and political that chose
to stay and those the chosen [ __ ] out of
below for me
he only came in ever well Bauman decided
to stay I think and what didn't really
decide to stay he wanted to get out like
anything because he knew perfectly well
that the others who were staying like
gurbles were determined to kill
themselves
now Borman did not want to kill himself
he'd always been a total opportunist of
the sneakiest snaky a sword and his he
in fact he was the one who was the whole
time was true when Speer turned up at
the bunker that last time Borman was
pleading with Speer to persuade Hitler
to leave above Bavaria because that
would have given Borman the opportunity
to get out but Goebbels was definitely
committed to the murder of his children
and self-immolation or killing himself
with his with his wife and that's why
all the others in fact also knowing that
that was the case you know if they
wanted to live they got out but the of
the senior officials it really depended
sort of what their position was and I
mean Hitler was it was in a sort of
various strange these mixed moods
particularly during that crucial day
rally of his
thirsty and then two days later when all
the evacuations were being decided and
who was allowed to leave and who was to
stay but certainly the vast majority of
officials were definitely trying to
wangle their ticket out and Bormann was
horrified when he was found himself
trapped there he had to stay with the
Hitler partly because there's one or two
historians are very rightly pointed out
Baumann's power entirely depended on
Hitler and the most dangerous moment for
him was going to be when Hitler died and
he although technically the head of the
Nazi Party was somehow going to have to
convert that position into real power
when faced with the rivalry of Himmler
Goering not who was actually by then a
completely spent force but above all
bubble faced faced with Himmler and
Goebbels well actually sorry Goebbels
would be killing himself but Himmler was
them was the chief rival anyway yes I
think we time for a couple more years in
1945 I was an intelligence officer at
Eisenhower's headquarters and I flew
from where the surrender was signed and
Reims to Flensburg where the German High
Command had finally been bottled up and
all the boys were there and but
everybody was there and the Russians
came because they insisted on being
there and they will put up board a boat
with us called the patria which was a
beautiful ocean line we should made one
trip and my job was to work with the
Russian officers to go through the
mountains of documents which were in
warehouses there and every time we come
across an interesting document the
Russians will say huh that's for us my
allies
guys don't need this and I didn't want
to tell them we know very little about
the Russian army order of battle ich was
my specialty so this happened time and
time again and every time we came across
an interesting document I refused to
give it to them
brought it back to my general we flew it
to London had copies made and a couple
of days later I gave you the documents
so that many many documents which they
did not want us to have was obtained by
us through that way and I can see where
your experiences at the archives there
all these documents must admit
something's dead change there's true
more than ever fascinate can I'd love to
have a work quick where we do off to it
always bother the main chance yes
I wasn't German military intelligence on
the Eastern Front better they there are
a series of very significant failures
and anticipating job Oh strengthen the
red army behind Stalingrad the 44
offensive and forty three offensive they
do better it's very difficult to tell
there's been a lot of argument over it
because Galen the head of from the Hara
asked was very careful in the way that
he phrased his intelligence predictions
they were they were remarkably Delphic
and they could always be read both ways
so you know a bit on the one hand and on
the other and all the rest of it then he
was always gonna say look I predicted it
you know but that of course didn't cut
much ice with Hitler he where where he
won must give him his due was it in 1945
his predictions were spot-on about the
massive Soviet attack coming in
mid-january and Hitler absolutely
refused to see it in fact he accused
Galen of what was it I can't remember at
you know total lunacy and madness or
whatever and Guderian the chief of staff
who completely backed
Galen's prediction said well you know if
he should be locked up I must be locked
up too because I completely agree with
you know what he has to say
but yes it's it's it's hard to say I
didn't think that Gailen got it
obviously it did certainly didn't get it
right a lot of the time on the Eastern
Front but that was partly because the
Red Army had actually acquired a
tremendous skill in what they describe
as a mask Hrothgar or whatever which was
deception by using dummy armies by feint
attacks and all the rest of it and
obviously not you're quite right 1944
and the destruction of Army Group centre
was certainly the most sort of
devastating example of that but to what
degree Gillan was ignored in to what
degree he was completely wrong I think
is still a matter for a certain amount
of debate I think
let's leave one last quick at the back
there were a few of them shot out of
hand I went through the Jean de Marie
look there what they called the their
equivalent of military police reports on
the stuttgart incident in a way to try
just not that I was writing about it in
the book but just to try to get some
sort of comparison or basis of
comparison with the behavior of the
Russian troops and there's a certain
amount of a certain amount of detail the
problem was that a lot of the the Jean
de Marie that private a story's the
phrase the Provost unit we're not there
up close to the front when they actually
got into stood guard so there was the
most appalling looting and sack of the
city and then I think partly to sort of
make up for the lack of inactivity the
provost Jean Dom's just grabbed a few of
the algerian soldiers and just sort of
shot him out of hand to give the
impression that they'd actually done
something to control the whole thing
there have been allegations which are
I'm afraid either impossible to deny or
disprove rather all proof that French
officers actively encouraged them in
this activity thinking it was quite
funny
and I mean you know what I've heard this
I have no idea I can't say whether it is
whether it is true or not but Stuttgart
was certainly the worst example on the
Western Front I think anyway well um
thank you all very much indeed